Babe. I'm going to go to the gym to work
out a little bit. You want to come with
me?
I just ordered an extra long straw to
avoid accidentally doing a sit up.
Look at this.
My brother. What's up, jackass?
Happy birthday, you dumb son of a
b****. My birthday's tomorrow, moron.
I never understood this relationship.
So.
63, right?
Hey, you can count.
You know.
Dad was 63 when he died, huh?
Hello. Thanks for reminding me.
Don't worry. He never took care of
himself. He ate like crap and drank too
much. Anyway, Irene's begging me.
Hey, Gloria, wait up. I'm coming.
Okay, baby. Hey, you little monkey.
No standing.
Around. There you go.
Here goes another one. There you go.
Hey, here comes Alan. There you go.
Oh, I thought you were one of ours.
Hey, Jay, be careful.
You're going to hurt.
Somebody, like you.
Don't get too comfortable. I reserved us
a tennis court.
Yay! I thought that one of the
advantages of marrying an older guy was
that I was going to be able to relax.
But all the swimming and running and
rowing, it's just like how some of my
relatives got into this country.
Where is Jay? He's not with you?
No, He came down a long time ago.
Oh, don't worry.
I'll go have a look around.
Yeah, he's probably in the ocean trying
to pull a tugboat with his teeth.
Jay.
Over here.
Hey. Hey, What are you doing?
I'm stuck.
I laid down my back. Went out.
Oh, well, don't you worry.
We're going to get you out of here.
Grab on.
You know, Phil, this might not be the
best.
No, no, no, no, no, no. I'm just going
to rock you like a hurricane.
I'm kidding. You're too old to get
that. Here we go. Wait.
Why don't you just get someone who works
here? No, this is.
Going to work. And.
Oh, wow.
Spasming. Don't move. Don't move.
Don't get.
Uh.
By the way, I just want to thank you for
this trip. It's really been a vacation
of a lifetime. Oh.
Nothing weird. Aloha.
I keep my wallet in my front pocket.
So that's. That's what that is.
Neck going.
I'm sorry. We say we'll make time, but
life gets in the way.
I mean, I know we're parents, but can't
we be lovers, too?
This may be my worst birthday ever.
There you are.
Hi.
Hey. He was stuck in a hammock.
It was actually really funny.
I was on top of him for, like, 20
minutes. Good night, honey.
My back seized.
Up. Yeah, because you overdid it after
that phone call about your father.
I can't believe I'm as old as he was.
Let me sit down here. Are you two like
them? My old man.
I'm sure.
And he had loved you.
My God, that guy.
He was a charmer.
I know the type.
Ah we had a lot of fun.
But I'll tell you something.
Our family vacations were nothing like
this here. One week a year in a rented
cottage on Lake Erie. Spiders this big?
I just wish he could have seen how
things turned out.
Well, if you keep going like this, maybe
you can tell him yourself.
Or I can tell him because you're about
to kill me. Jay. My legs, my arms, my
back. Everything is sore.
So I wore you out, huh?
No, no, no. Don't get cocky, old man.
When I sit down, I can still get up.
Hey.
Okay. Come on.
Come here. Come here.
The rest of the trip went better.
Haley's room stopped spinning.
Yes, it is. Mind the.
Monkey. Hi.
Honey. Hey, you want some eggs Benedict?
So creamy.
No. Jay got back to the vacation he
always wanted. And Mitch and Cam
managed to do some sightseeing at a
working banana plantation where they
promptly lost Lily again.
Why did you dress her in jungle print?
Because I thought it would be cute.
You kind of think she's back in
Vietnam. Lily.
Lily. Honey.